[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so welcome everyone to day two of julia
con
my name is oscar and i'm going to be
moderating this session
we're doing things a little bit
differently for this keynote we're
recording it live now
but we will also restream it at 2 30 pm
utc
so if you're joining us from that later
time
welcome so the reason we're restreaming
we're streaming this early is because
our keynote speaker jeremy howard is
joining us from australia
uh jeremy is a serial entrepreneur uh
the former president and chief scientist
of kegel and the founder of fast ai
an organization that aims to make deep
learning as accessible as possible
uh they have a python package of the
same name and various educational
resources and he recently released a new
edition of his online course practical
deep learning for coders which if he
doesn't mention
i would encourage you to check out on
youtube
if you're watching us live you can ask
questions from this pigeonhole link
at the bottom of the screen and i'll try
and summarize them
for the end
you can also chat in the green channel
of discord
uh surely i'm going to add jeremy's
screens to the
screen
generally slides to the screen and then
i'll pop out and then i'll be back at
the end
to moderate some questions
so with that jeremy over to you
thanks very much
so
today i want to talk about
what makes a programming language
successful
and i'm going to talk about why
i care about that particularly for julia
i've been
coding for about 40 years
and coding nearly every day for the last
30
and
i've tried and used a lot of different
programming languages
julia is
one of my favorite um as a programming
language
i think it's quite magnificent and
presumably anybody who's uh
involved in this conference must feel
the same way
so i'm going to share
some things that i particularly like
um about julia
i guess everybody might have their own
different feelings about
uh
what they like
but here are some of the things that i
think are very very special
about this programming language
um
what you see on the screen here is
actually a library i wrote for python
um it's a
type dispatch library in fact it's
called type dispatch and as you can see
are examples of what is type dispatch
and why it's interesting
actually
in julia
i like the way that
dispatch method dispatch is handled in
julia so much that i wrote a library to
try to copy it in python
um having said that
my python version is never going to be
as good as the real thing
the way that type dispatch is done in
julia
neatly solves the age-old expression
problem
which has plagued computer science and
software engineering for years and
allows us to really flexibly
uh
tie behavior to not just types but to
combinations of types
and i think that's
really
quite fantastic
and there's no other language i know of
that handles this so well
including python despite the fact i
wrote
a library to try and do it
um
having said that if you do use python
use fastcore because it makes you makes
it look more like julia which everybody
agrees i think is a good thing
something else i really like about julia
is a lot of the libraries are
beautifully and elegantly designed
so for example the library used for the
very simple feature of calling out to
the shell calling external processes
um
is just
it's just better designed than really
anything else i've seen or certainly
anything else anything else i've seen
that's built into
the standard library of a programming
language so for example writing multiple
commands in parallel in julia
you know it looks just like it does
in bash
but it's it's it's real julia um and
then you can do really amazing things
like piping um
parallel processes to another command
and i don't think i've ever seen
anything quite like that before
and the whole thing is done in a very um
a very elegant way there are um simple
easily understood pieces that work
behind the scenes together really well
to allow you to express
anything you want
now i
mainly work in ai and particularly deep
learning nowadays
and as you might know
we do
pretty much everything on gpus or tpus
or accelerators
something that is
nearly unique
about julia
is that we can write
tight
looping code that's going to run on the
gpu
um
in julia
and it's not you know there's less
boilerplate
than you would see pretty much in any
other language
um it's and it it it just works it just
works beautifully
and part of the so not only is that
fantastic and important because you know
in python
we can't really do this there are some
libraries like number which
kind of let us do it but but it's it's
nothing
as elegant or as effective as this
and one of the key reasons this is
possible is because of how elegant meta
programming is
in julia so the the ability to to do
meta programming to actually
change how the code is compiled and run
at the lowest level
and to write that in julia um is quite
extraordinary and so i think this is a
very
you know special
you know uh
capability of this language
now something that might be surprising
to care about but that i care about a
lot
is that
the vast majority of julia
is written in julia
and the vast majority of the actual code
that that behind the scenes is being run
when i created julia program
is julia code
um
there is
you know at the lowest level
um a
a scheme-ish parser there are bits of
cnc plus plus they're kind of doing
interrupt with llvm and stuff but you
know most of most of it is julia and so
you know here's here's the type
inference algorithm
um
now why do i care about this well i care
about this for a number of reasons um
the first is i do a lot of teaching
and if i can't
you know debug into the actual code
that's running
then it's very hard for me to show my
students
what's really going on you know in
python
the vast majority of the code we're
really running is actually written
in c
we're just writing kind of python
wrappers on it so if i'm trying to say
this is what's actually happening under
the hood
i can't do that you know using a python
debugger i can't use that using a python
ide to jump into the code and explain it
and this is a real problem
for for teaching
this is also another reason that the gpu
stuff's so important i can actually show
the gpu kernel code itself
it's more than that though
it's it's also the hackability um this
is something that um i talked a lot
about with
chris latina who um i worked with when
we were trying to look at
bringing fast ai and deep learning onto
swift
um and uh he's he's the inventor of
swift and llvm and you know he talked
about this idea of hackability a
language where you can write
all of the pieces of the language in the
language itself means that you can go in
and change things and understand things
and
this is just really important you know i
i'm an academic
as well as teaching i do research
i want to implement my ideas in code
if i have to you know switch into c
to do that to be honest i'm probably not
going to bother um you know it's a whole
different language a different
development environment i have to worry
about compiling and setting up you know
all that stuff
and it's just going to be a lot more
verbose
in practice in deep learning very very
few of us in the research world ever
go down to that level
but if i can write stuff in a higher
level programming language like julia
that's going to make a world of
difference to the kind of research that
i'm going to be prepared to do because i
can i can hack at anything
the package management and julia is also
terrific now this is not unique to julia
to be honest the package management and
julia is nearly identical to a package
manager in python called conda
but that's not a bad thing that's a good
thing the conda package manager for
python is fantastic
in both cases
it's not just julia code or python code
that you can package but in you know all
of the binary pieces the libraries the
executables
and so forth
versioning dependencies all handled as
well
and so that is
great news i also love by the way that
the repel is a big part of julia i am a
huge believer in report-driven
programming languages and real rebel
driver driven kind of programming
methods
um and i've written a lot of stuff for
that in python so the fact that you know
there's even a separate package rebel i
mean that's that's just super cool
um so julie is an amazing language with
all these fantastic pieces libraries
great ecosystem
so when you look at
something like this i mean this is uh
the um
one particular listing of of
soft of programming language
popularity
where's julia
and the answer is it's
off the screen
just behind cobol
now nobody's going to say this is the
world's most perfect
programming language popularity listing
but
there's lots of different ones and they
all basically show julia being around
about
25 26 27
um and not improving actually you know
in many cases
getting worse
um
so this is
um this is a bit surprising this is a
bit odd what's going on you know i think
we all remember
in the early days of julia you know the
way we tended to think of this as being
like well
it's a new language
people haven't heard of it people just
haven't come to terms with how cool it
is yet
um but i don't think at this stage
we can accept that that's the reason
so i spend most of my time
working in python
which is
according to this particular index
different one
the world's most popular language and
also the growing the fastest in the last
five years
um
you know i i'm somebody who loves
dabbling in all kinds of different
languages
but there is something
very nice
about working in a very popular language
which is that
when more people are working on a
language
there's more stuff for it you know
there's more of the things that i want
to do that somebody's gone out and done
for me or there'll often be multiple
different versions and i can find the
one that works best for my needs
so
here's what i want
i want julia to be used more
widely um now look not maybe not
everybody feels that way and that's fine
um but that's that's my starting point i
like julia i'm a julie enthusiast i
would like more people to be using it
apart from anything else the more people
that are using julia the more people
that are making it better the more
that's being invested into it the more
libraries that are going to appear for
it
um
you know i think it's it's it's healthy
and nice to be working with a
programming language which is widely
used
i personally want to use julia more
in fact today
i use it barely at all
this may sound surprising having given
all this praise about how much i like
julia
but the truth is
much as i like the language
it's very hard for me to actually use it
for anything
in my work or even in my hobbies and i
think the reasons for that have got a
lot to do with the reasons that
few people are actually using julia much
out there in the world
and so
i want to talk about the things that i
think that maybe julia could do
to be more usable for me and to get more
usage from other people
and as i say these might not be goals
that you share in which case the rest of
this talk will not be of interest you
but if there are goals you share
hopefully you'll find these thoughts
useful
so i want to kind of do is think about
what makes a programming language
successful
and to do that i think
an important starting point is to
consider a particular kind of
taxonomy of programming languages
um which there's a lot of hand waving
i'm going to do here so bear with me but
hand waverly i'm going to describe there
as being two types of language those
which
kinda don't have a runtime
and those which do have a runtime or a
virtual machine or whatever
generally speaking the main big
difference between these will be about
how they handle memory
so
those that have a runtime
are going to look after memory for you
okay so they're generally going to have
a
garbage collection most commonly
including julia so julie is a garbage
collected language
those without a run time
are going to do less for you you're
going to have to do more work so in the
case of c you have to do all the memory
handling yourself in the case of c plus
there's lots of different options such
as raii
in the case of swift there's a very
sophisticated kind of reference counting
which can happen at compile time
and in rust there's the infamous or
famous uh borough checker
working without a runtime
you know is harder it's more work all of
these languages are more difficult to
use
um because of these issues around how
you have to handle memory
and so julia is in this in this class of
languages which are generally going to
be easier to use because they have a
runtime looking after things like in
particular memory for you
now why does that matter
when we're thinking about what makes a
language popular
well that's because these different
types of languages make very different
compromises
and they put them in very different
places
so
those that don't have a runtime
there's a lot you can do with them
so if
the memory if you have to handle the
memory yourself it's kind of being
handled at the compilation stage so
there's not a runtime
then you end up with an artifact
which can be a totally self-contained
app generally it's going to be very
small in size that you can distribute to
somebody
you can even put it on a mobile phone
um you could embed it in another app
even an app that that that does have a
runtime because remember this thing's
kind of standalone it's handling all its
own memory
uh or you can do interrupt so for
example
python
there are lots of
packages designed to be used in python
which are not written in python so for
example
the company hugging face has a library
called tokenizers which is very
important in natural language processing
which is written in rust
and but the key
audience for this
package is python programmers
and so because rust is a
non-run time again hand wavy non-run
time language it's very easy to use rust
from python
um that's definitely not the case of
these
other languages
so
because these ones all have you know a
virtual machine or you know their own
kind of
memory stuff going on in their runtime
it's it's they're not generally very
good for
any of these things
generally they can be done but not
necessarily going to be done well
so
let's look at the group that julia is in
languages with a runtime
so as far as i can tell
there are two broad classes of
li of languages with runtimes that that
do well that are popular or at least
popular with certain groups of people
one group are the languages which do
everything
pretty well
so python does everything pretty well
java does everything pretty well go does
everything pretty well they all have all
kinds of
constraints all kinds of things that you
know you'd wish it was a bit better as a
python programmer there's a thousand
things in python i'm
not quite happy with but i can do
anything in it then there's another
group of languages
which do one thing
really well
languages like matlab
mathematica slash wolfram
and labview you know they have their
niches
where they can be very very popular
and um you know another example might be
something like k slash q slash you know
kdb in the array programming world used
everywhere in hedge funds
you know these are kind of uh things
that are fairly standalone they're
fairly niche
generally speaking
nearly all of the languages i can think
of in this category of doing one thing
really well
tend to be proprietary commercial
languages
so it's often being marketed to a
particular
industry sub-segment
so matlab for example is very widely
used in engineering
as far as i can tell
this isn't really the direction that
most people i think want julia to go
so i think that leaves julia in the
category of like well to try to do
everything pretty well
so i'm going to call those flexible
runtime languages so the languages with
a runtime that can do everything pretty
well
and so here are three examples
of very successful
flexible runtime languages
so
the first one
we'll look at is go
so go i'm kind of picking a few things
for each of these languages which
i feel like are fundamental
to their success
so for go
you can create a standalone application
so remember all of these are flexible so
they can do anything right but in
particular and go you can create a
standalone application
it's got a fantastic cross compiler so
you can create it for any operating
system and
um and hardware platform in the
list of supported ones
and that application that you create is
going to start fast
and it's going to run pretty fast as
well
so this is great because it can
do anything and then you end up with a
thing that you can give somebody and say
here here's a thing you can use or you
can chuck it up on your web server and
your web server can use it so that is a
really nice
set of things to have to work together
so what about python
well one of the things about python
that's very interesting is it's
pre-installed nearly everywhere
which is something that is also true of
perl for example although that's less
popular now um so mac comes with python
pretty much every linux distribution
comes with python
windows it doesn't exactly come with
python but if you hit start and type
python it's there's a link built into
the system that takes you to the windows
store microsoft store where a single
click will have it installed so it's
very very easy for anybody
to run the python script
a second really important thing about
python is
many or most universities basically use
it as their starting coding language for
um for most folks that need to learn the
code
so we now have a lot of people in the
world who know a bit of python
and then partly thanks to these two
things the partly thanks that's been
around for a while there's the most
amazing package ecosystem for python in
that
almost anything you can think of there's
going to be a few pretty good packages
around they'll generally be documented
they'll generally be maintained
for doing whatever you want to do
so as a python programmer these are all
things which um are pretty interesting
to this ecosystem um
i love working with a language where
lots of people know it because i can
build things that lots of people can use
and that makes me feel good because i
love building things lots of people can
use
um
you know then there's java which apart
from anything else it's just been around
a really long time
so it's developed a lot of users and in
particular a lot of enterprise users and
it's got a really strong enterprise
focus
so
so java has a lot of
inertia
and so there's just a lot of companies
that use it and also because it's been
around a long time there's a lot of
there's a pretty good ecosystem of
packages around for it as well
i wouldn't say it's anywhere near as as
broad and interesting as the python
ecosystem but it's still pretty good
so these are all languages which have
reasons
for their success
and if
julia's going to be a
flexible
runtime language
what's julia's reason for success going
to be so we've got what do we got here
one two three four five six seven okay
it's eight things for these three
so here's those eight things
um
julia
uh let's see what has julia got julia is
never probably going to get
pre-installed on just about every
operating system
it's probably not going to be the de
facto
education
coding language um
[Music]
getting an ecosystem as big as python's
probably not going to happen at least
not for a long time and not unless it's
very popular
big enterprise like java probably not
um long history i mean that only happens
over time right so that's not something
that's going to happen enough in a hurry
so what we're left with
here
um is
um
there's my little button here there we
go
um so what we're left with here is maybe
these three things
um standalone apps
cross compiler fast start maybe those
are things which
that julia could have now these are the
three things
that all are in the go category and i
think goes very interesting for julia
because
go
started in 2009
julia started in 2009.
go is a garbage collected language julia
is a garbage collective language here
are two languages that both have the
same basic approach to kind of memory
management they both started at about
the same time
and i guess we got to be honest
go's been a lot more successful
a lot of people are using it it's i
think in the top 10 of many
popularity indexes
and again like popularity is not the be
all at end or but if more people are
using our language of choice
then generally speaking that's a good
thing
because more stuff's getting built for
it and there's more people who
understand it and it's just nice to see
things that we like doing well um at
least that's how i feel um
so it's you know it's interesting to
kind of look at go as a role model of
like well what what did they do
you know and as i say
you know i think these
three things
are critical
um and they're things which
would make all the difference for me as
a julia enthusiast who's not a julia
user
because at the moment i kind of find
myself thinking
you know
what
what do i do
with my julia thing that i build
like
you know i want to create a web app i
can put on a website or or a program i
can
put out there for people to download and
install it's it's not a great
kind of like what do i do with it in
fact
you know here's an example of somebody
asking i'm new to julia i just started
loving this language at first sight
elegant
dot dot dot when i build something now i
want to convert it to an exe
answer
this is the most feared question of the
community there is no real world usable
approach now let's compare that to what
happens in go
save your file as main.go
type this command okay copy the binary
now that is nice right that's a thing
and look it's not only that but i can
pick here what operating system do i
want to compile for
what platform do i want to compile for
and i end up with a single file that i
can put up on my website i can give to
my friend i can stick on my web server
i've built something that i can use and
that people can use that is awesome
that's what i code for
and so not being able to do that
is a problem
now
these are all things that
people in the giulio community
have
tried to do things about
but
nobody's quite put it all together right
into the like delightful developer or
user experience that you know usability
is so important that i want to be able
to type this you know type a line of
code
there's my file
stick it on the web server
that's
that's what it needs to be like
and it kind of feels like a lot of the
pieces are getting there right now you
know there are pieces that
aren't going to be a solution to this
problem like static compiler for example
you know julia
is never going to be a great statically
compiled language um but the pieces like
you know artifacts and you know package
compiler and you know there's all these
pieces
maybe even things like the daemonizer
i'm not sure exactly what the components
are but there's a lot of components out
there which maybe you're just about
ready to be the point where you could do
this and you know this would be the
thing that i think would make
so many people say okay we are we always
knew julia is a beautiful language well
he's always known it's got beautiful
libraries and now i can build things
with it which people can use
and
it's not like julia's going to be
exactly competing with go because julia
fills in goes missing pieces
right for example go doesn't have
operator overloading
so speaking with somebody that does a
lot of
mathematics a lot of science uh encoding
not being able to use
operators
in the way that they're used in my
domain
is a nightmare right and i just wouldn't
feel comfortable i don't feel
comfortable in a language that doesn't
let me
use my operators properly
um you know it's it's also the the go
type system is
is pretty basic right and and julia's is
pretty rich
um and then on top of that of course is
the very elegant dispatch mechanism that
we've already talked about and you know
this group of things together
along with the overall design of the
language lets me write
concise
expressive
code
now
not everybody wants
to work in such a language and that's
fine go
has very intentionally decided not to go
for concise and expressive
but to create something incredibly
simple
that
might take a lot more to write
but
you know maybe it's easier to learn or
maybe it's easier not to mess up i don't
know like it's not the way i like to
code but i know there's a lot of people
who like
that about go
but of course there's a lot of people
like me who don't right and
in particular for scientific programming
you know generally speaking i want to
try and write the code in a way that
looks like the paper that i'm
implementing you know and that tends to
be much more using kind of concise and
expressive notation
and then on top of that you know gpu
programming or tpu programming or you
know accelerated programming
in my field and ai that's just
absolutely necessary and go doesn't
really do that at least not in any
comfortable way
and then put all this together
and you know these are some of the key
ingredients for creating good scientific
libraries
and
julia already has a lot of excellent
scientific libraries go really doesn't
so
julia fits into a kind of a different
place
right and it's a place which
there's nothing else there right now you
know
um speaking of something you know this
is this is the thing i want i want
something with with all of julia's
beauty
um all of julia's great points
um
but something that i
can create something that people can use
right
um and i think that there's a
hundreds of thousands maybe millions of
people in the world who want
that thing
i want to go to a web page it says type
this one line of code press enter and
there's the thing that you give people
so
that's
my
vision
of what i would like to see you know i
would like
a language which is exactly like julia
in every way
and
really nothing's changed
but the difference is that i can build
software that i can
give to people that people can use that
i can use very easily to
run a web server to check on our website
um you know it it it needs to
start quickly you know so that so that
that single file that i create with a
single line of code needs to start
quickly uh not use too much ram
um it's okay if it's
20 meg you know that's no problem
we can send 20 meg you know
sap a 20 meg file to a web server
zip it up and stick it on google drive
check you know make it in a
github release whatever like that's how
go binaries are they're not small
but they start pretty quickly and they
don't use too much memory at least
compared to julia right they they are
practical and they are usable and i
would love something just like that
but with all of the wonderful pieces of
julia thrown in
um
okay so that's that's my thoughts about
you know where maybe julia can fit in
the in the world of programming
languages i think there's a
key place for it to fill i don't think
it's quite there yet but maybe it's not
that far
and so if anybody has any questions i
would be happy to take them
thanks very much i think that was um
a very interesting talk and i'm sure it
will spur a lot of
uh discussion going forward i hope so
one one thing i had um that immediately
popped to mind at the end was he said
that it doesn't matter if the
binary is 20 megabytes
but what about say 200 megabytes i think
some of the
package compiler things if you do at the
moment kind of in that kind of order of
magnitude is that a problem
yeah i don't know i mean
it's getting to the problem stage like
not necessarily like
for for something i'm tracking on a web
server
maybe not
you know like if that feels okay
uh for something i'm putting as a github
release
like
you don't want to be at the point where
like github's going to be saying like oh
that needs to go in large file storage
or whatever i can't remember where that
limit is i don't i think it's still
probably okay
um yeah that's in the like
i'm not quite sure it's it's close to
the limit of what you could get away
with it be worth trying
but but ideally we should be aiming for
20 or less yeah or maybe 50 yeah
another question that came up was
how important do you think having a
corporate sponsor for the languages
so go and jabba have had
quite a lot of commercial backing python
i guess hasn't historically but in
recently it kind of has more people
joining in but how much of that is a an
important factor yeah i think python's a
good example of like not needing
corporate sponsorship if you are a
really flexible language that everybody
wants to use
because then
you end up with the thousands of
corporate sponsors
you know there are people that are using
your language every day and needed to be
successful you know
you could say the same about linux you
could say the same about llvm and you
know like
llvm and playing i guess they're kind of
well i mean they don't really have a
corporate sponsor so i think like
what's important is to have users
you know to have users that are using it
for stuff that people care about
building software that people
use not just users but people who build
things that things that themselves have
users
and you know speaking as somebody who
develops a lot of software packages
um
you know we we try very hard to
highlight
the big companies that use the code that
we
write
because we know that's going to give
people comfort of saying like okay so
for example just today we launched
a new version of our library for
literate and exploratory programming
called nbdev
and
you know we really highlighted you know
the companies like netflix and lyft and
so forth that use nbdev on our home page
because yeah we feel that people knowing
that these companies are using this
they're going to be
making sure that it works well that
they'll be putting
time into keeping it you know
maintaining it and so forth
so i had uh
another question so we compared uh say
go and python and java
what about r that seems to be a kind of
another language that's similar to julia
trying to do
uh statistical and mathematical stuff
how does that fit in
yeah i mean r um
okay so r comes from s
and s
was originally available to you know
in the public as s plus
um
it's got history on its side it's been
around for a long time so when i started
doing statistical computing
it was actually before
uh even s plus really was out there and
in those days it was kind of spss and
sas
they were
very expensive systems that none of us
particularly liked and when s plus came
along that felt like a big step and so
for for statistical computing
that felt kind of like a bit of a
monopoly you know that that was the
thing that you wanted to use and then
when r came along
it's like oh it's the same language that
we've already been using but now it's
free you know and open source and so we
all switched or at least i switched and
everybody i knew switched to r
so that's a language which has
kind of this space
because it kind of had a monopoly and
it's been around for many decades
um
you know a lot of people i know that use
ah today use it for a couple of reasons
the first is
you know that's what they've always used
that's what everybody at the university
or whatever uses
um particularly popular in kind of
academic circles um and also
you know it's a lot of it's because of
one man
which is hadley wickham who's created a
set of beautiful libraries that have a
better developer experience for kind of
data munching and stuff like that than
than any other language
i think also a lot of it's got to do
with with our studio and jj elaire who
have built a fantastic free development
environment in art studio
but even that
um i'm not sure that ours gonna
keep thriving
you know you may have seen us as just
today
our studio renamed to posit
because it's now going to focus on
python more um you know increasingly
when i talk to people using r they
almost sound a bit apologetic about it
and they're kind of like oh don't worry
i'm going to start learning python soon
i know that i've got to
um so i think that's an example of a
language that's actually maybe
a bit too niche
and hasn't quite
got what it takes to really continue to
to thrive
well we'll see i'd be happy to be wrong
you know i like i say i do feel like
hadley's libraries are
the best in the world for doing what
they do
um but personally i you know i used to
use
s plus and r
you know for all my statistical work and
now i never ever use it so that probably
gives you a sense of
how much i in the end i really did or
didn't enjoy the language itself
i'll say that i'm coming to you from
auckland new zealand so i can't say that
about uh
um one question uh is uh what's your
relationship to the fast ai dot jl
package
to the fast ai dot jl so there's a julia
package called fast ai
how does that fit in
um
enthusiastic supporter that's that's all
you know i um
i i think it looks very impressive so
fast ai.jl is a
you know idiomatically
julia
reimagining of the fast ai python
library for deep learning
um
and
you know we went through a similar
experience when we tried to create fast
ai for swift or we did create fast aa
for swift
which is that languages like swift and
julia
don't lend themselves to the kind of
highly dynamic approaches that we use
very extensively in our code for fast ai
and um
in swift you kind of got to use more of
you know immutable stuff pretty much
everywhere and then julia you know i
guess there was a bit of decision to to
go down that path
and so i think you know they've ended up
with a very
very very interesting
um
package
it's
still fairly incomplete
it you know
it would be great to get to see it get
more love um it's been mainly the
the hard work and passion of one person
in particular and i think it's amazing
what they've what they've achieved so
far um and i would love to see it um
yeah go even
further i think procrastinating grad
students have built most of the the
julia ecosystem
so one question was can you expand on
your thoughts about why julia may not be
competitive for teaching
oh i think it can be competitive for
teaching but just like
i don't think i don't think like you're
gonna get into the first year university
course as the first coding option for
every university in the world in the
next five years you know like it's a
that's something that happens
after a language is hugely popular and
has been for 10 years you know so um
before python
it was java
all the introductory courses tend to be
in java
um and then i guess after a while
people started noticing like gee there's
a lot of boilerplate in java and you're
messing around with all this kind of
compilation and virtual machine and blah
blah blah you know people started trying
python because they've seen it been
popular for a long time it's widely used
in industry and they realized they could
teach
you know explain how to create
a web server you know or how to create a
command line application or how to
create a gui
in just a few lines of code and focus on
on those
i i think julia could absolutely do
those things
but um
you know it it would first need to be
one of the world's most popular
languages and then be in that position
for 10 years and then you might be in
the situation where everybody uses it
for teaching
okay that brings us uh to the end of
time so
i want to thank jeremy uh for giving a a
very interesting tour and i'm sure that
there will be a lot of uh discussion
going forward on on some of the topics
that were raised
so thank you everyone
uh enjoy the rest of your juliacon